butin
nouveau phénomène s'est vraiment bien
ici à rennes en bas monde c'est génial
j'adore très client depuis le début et
là il faut aller le voir la tournée
quand même date ces normes
il ya beaucoup de dates ouais il ya
beaucoup beaucoup de dates et jetés
après j'avoue champions dormi là ouais
bah oui c'est normal c'est un peu là
mais ça il ya vraiment beaucoup
d'attelage attaque à annecy le premier
est maintenant offert une interview psy
titoff on est moche marc dans les
guignols on ne bouge pas pendant le
jingle
si l'internaute si si est ce que vous
êtes mytho non non ne thomann non non
j'aime bien dans le spectacle il ya
beaucoup de personnages qui sont
complètement mytho mais moi dans la vie
je suis pas je suis pas spécialement me
thonon non et je détecte souvent les les
mythomanes j'adore ça comme ça quelqu'un
qui arrive commence à parler que sa part
il commence à raconter n'importe quoi ça
c'est fabuleux
c'est une des textes là où d'ailleurs je
vous écoute et il croit et lui raconte
est ce que vous êtes
skeezo zizou zizou aussi schizo ouais
ouais ouais ben obligatoirement un coup
quant à ma science quand on va sur scène
mais c'est pas non plus très loin de ce
que je suis dans la vie parano parano
complètement complètement croyais que
tout le monde vous déteste du mal de
vous non non mais je suis parano qua non
mais avec son frère et son copain au
plus tôt et un peu parano non mais ça
donne un exemple ce titre en vitesse je
ne fais pas la paranoïa par rapport à
par rapport à ça par exemple mais par
pour plein de trucs je fais s'il ya un
bruit ou je fais je bloque vite parano
voilà bien je suis pas parano je sais ça
c'est pas parano c'est trop de choses
qui arrivent je ne parle pas dans mon
émission vous poser la question sur le
câble vient maso non vous n'aimez pas
les simples ça c'est bon c'est pas
pareil
c'est pas j'aime bien les sages aime
bien châtie mais pas jusqu'à la douleur
abattant justin c'est comme ça dans les
petits frissons
il est sympa c'est dommage qu'ils
regardent battu à celle fille bien
est-ce que vous êtes sado ça donnera non
je ne va pas faire mal
non une petite fille si de temps en
temps il va j'ai bien aimé la petite
fessée cantal ont bien mérité les titres
et c'est là je te regarde encore une
fois mais oui oui ben t'es pas obligé de
la prochaine question ce n'est pas
obligée de regarder mais est-ce que vous
êtes chaude au site
enfin franchement oui bailly si on
répond franchement bien tout le temps
mais moi je réponds tout temps
franchement de la vie je suis pas un
passionné un bon jeu non c'est pendant
l'annoncé wayne dans un des fois quand
pour donner un petit peu de piquant
c'est à dire c'est un peu comme les
aventuriers parlant tiens tu parlais
dans ce pays
et oui vous êtes sur france 2 chaîne du
service public mesdames messieurs je
vais être exhibo bizarrement je suis
assez chasse est réservé et c'est par
exemple j'aime pas téléphoner devant des
gens et certains trucs mais c'est vrai
que faire faire l'amour dans d'autres
personnes
ouais ça peut être sympa
on peut y aller il ya du bon ben là il
ya 2 3 millions de gens est ce que vous
êtes homo ah non je voulais être trio
oui là la première fois la vertu mais
non non à la met pas en garde s'applique
très bien me dire d'aller chercher une
bière dans le frigo
ouais ouais est ce que vous êtes fétiche
au nom pas porno pour garder des
cassettes pornos ça m'a passé ça je
trouve ça ridicule mais c'est vers 12
présent de votre époque
ouais bah c'était les débuts par contre
a dit poilu est ce que vous êtes géronto
gérante on constate des gens plus vieux
à
ah non non une fille de 32 ans mais bon
ouais voilà jusqu'à 40 d'accord parce
que jusqu'à 50 60
je vous ai jo moi je fais pas ton
dessinateur luc six mois oui oui mais
ces interviews qu surtout y en a qui m'a
envoyé un e-mail dit non non il ya un
mec qui m'a envoyé un e-mail pourquoi tu
te demande pas aux invités quand tu fais
l'interlude si vous avez de la chance
c'est pas tomber sur vous on vous a vu
et toi non plus est ce que vous êtes
nécro à non scato on n'est pas
uniquement maintenant jusqu'à tôt par
exemple n'ont pas dit ce classement et
est ce que vous êtes
adamo non adamo qu'est ce que tu attends
parade amoureuse qu'on est madame
brotcorne gamme adamo oui oui alors je
refoule dire que de mettre à de diana
beau voilà donc j'étais que sur le
maintien ou jamais entendre aux la
question est ce que vous êtes adamo
pendant l'acte sexuel c'est obligatoire
une fois d'amour pour lui sinon j'y
arrive pas